welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness is clearly showing us that
something is very much wrong with the
mcu multiverse which has us here at new
rockstars begging the very obvious
question who did it like who needs to go
to jail who in the mcu is actually to
blame for the high crime of reality
desecration i don't know about you but
new york did not look like that the last
time the sorcerer supreme wong saw it so
you know somebody has got to go to jail
well from the trailers we do hear from
mordo that strange's desecration of
reality will not go unpunished but is
that actually true is dr strange
actually the one who'd done goofed and
messed up the entire multiverse so let
us count strange's cosmic crimes my nerd
babies because it's law and order mcu
okay so again our first teaser for
doctor strange is the multiverse of
madness has mordo telling strange that
his desecrations against reality will
not go unpunished before revealing to
all of us by the teaser's end that the
greatest threat to the multiverse was
doctor strange himself with this
long-haired mordo even going as far as
to fight a handcuffed version of our
doctor strange in that first teaser
footage an intense moment that i'm
assuming occurs after doctor strange is
handcuffed and brought in by these
ultron sentries of professor x's
illuminati but what could long-haired
bordeaux have meant by this well from
what we know from original recipe mordo
at the end of doctor strange 1 is that
this dude was obsessed with the
preservation of what he called the
natural law especially when doctor
strange gets a little bit too excited
about the cool new time traveling green
fruity pebble and attempts to restore
the page that the dark doofus of a
devoted dormammu stand quesillus stole
because when strange does this mordo
specifically chastises him about the
dangers of messing with the natural law
and the consequences of messing with the
natural law
they don't sound too good temporal
manipulations can create branches in
time
unstable dimensional openings
spatial paradoxes time loops yeah those
all sound slightly worse than lions
tigers and bears oh my and all of those
things are what could happen when you
create a paradox with the time stone you
know like when the universe sort of
corrected itself after strange created
the spatial paradox of having two of the
same dormammu page exist in two
different physical locations at the same
time because casilius had the page and
dr strange went back in time and made
the page that can't happen so the
universe was like ah we're i'm doing
this
so this being said i cannot help but
think that doctor strange's usage of the
time stone on the planet titan to see
the outcomes of the coming thanos
conflict could have been the exact
moment where doctor strange broke
reality the hardest because if you think
about it this is the only moment doctor
strange has used the time stone to peer
into the mcu multiverse for the very
specific purpose of writing his own
version of the events to come rather
than those that were naturally supposed
to occur if strange did not use the time
stone on titan because it wasn't just
one reality that strange was interfering
with technically it was
14605 something that mordo and even wong
would probably have 100
a huge problem with but hey that's what
happens when you leave your stephen
unsupervised they go rogue like steve at
the end of end game he went to see his
girlfriend just breaking the rules just
to get laid but i understand it i
understand which could be the reason for
all of those unstable dimensional
openings that appear in both trailers
for multiverse of madness we could be
seeing the bill coming due of doctor
strange using the time stone to prevent
half of all of life in the universe from
permanently dying through the opening of
wormholes to different points in
space-time the nerdiest lamest sentence
i've ever said
much like we saw during the convergence
when huge portals of gravitational
disturbances opened up throughout the
universe in thor 2 because if you
remember cars and city debris were
floating everywhere too during that
whole dark elf fiasco in london much
like they are in new york in this dr
strange footage and it was because of
those weird fluctuations in gravity due
to the convergence wormholes appearing
in the sky and this could be exactly why
mordo told strange that he could walk
strange's path no longer at the end of
doctor strange one because he saw
strange use the time stone to reverse
wong's death in the deaths of everyone
who died in case hillary's his initial
successful attack on hong kong as well
as use it to stop dormammu and he knew
that this curious student strange would
not be able to stop there so he just
dipped because he knew of the cubbing
cosmic consequences because he basically
saw k sillius turned to the dark side
himself and his former master and hey
before we continue this video is brought
to you by the ridge the ridge wallet is
light sleek and industrial and it's
designed to fit in your front pocket
unlike those bulky back pocket wallets
that we won't talk about stupid old
school wallets what are you doing the
ridge wallet holds up to 12 cards and
still has room for cash the ridge wallet
comes in over 30 styles and colors
including carbon fiber and burnt
titanium which is what i got right here
and there's even an 18 carat gold-plated
wallet which i think aisha and the other
shiny sovereign folks from guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 would probably
appreciate because they're all very gold
and i really like how strong and sturdy
the ridge wallet feels like this is not
a product that is going to bend or crack
if you sit on it weird or drop it on the
ground like literally check this out
i'm trying to bend it and it's not
happening the only thing that's going to
break is my will to break this wall
it's literally so
very sturdy and every ridge wallet comes
with a lifetime guarantee and they'll
let you test drive it for 45 days and
send it back for a full refund if you do
not love it and it's got 30 000 5 star
reviews so you'll probably love it 30
000 5 stars is like 150 000 stars that's
a lot of stars and ridge also has great
backpacks and travel bags with rfid
blocking pockets and optional device
charging batteries so get 15 off today
with free worldwide shipping and returns
by going to ridge.com new rockstars that
is ridge.com
new rockstars and be sure to use the
code new rockstars so please find the
link in the video's description but
outside of strange's abuse of the power
to the time stone we can't really talk
about crimes against reality and not
mention strange's regular use of the
ruins of cough call spell that we
learned about in spider-man no way home
because before wong's departure in the
film we learn that apparently doctor
strange has regularly used a dangerous
spell that travels the dark borders
between known and unknown reality which
in my eyes is referring to that dark
space in the dark void between universes
which is something that i think was
alluded to at the beginning of the loki
finale those two separate black holes
being two separate universes and the
darkness between them being that
darkness that wong is referring to
because let's be real if doctor strange
has been using such a powerful spell
that could potentially affect humanity
on a multiversal level like we saw with
the accidental cosmic yoinking of dafoe
and the foes and the venom who comes and
goes and with arguably the most powerful
member of the illuminati having roots in
the realm of the mind i'm sure that
professor xavier is probably one of the
few people in the mcu multiverse that
could even withstand and detect the
memory wiping effects of the multiverse
affecting runes of cough call spell and
is arresting strange for his abuses of
that spell because if you think about it
unfortunately doctor strange and
professor xavier are not unalike in this
way with xavier having used his own
powers of mental manipulation to place
mental blocks on the cosmically powerful
jean grey to cage the phoenix force
inside of her much to logan's shock and
protest i'm trying to restore the
psychic blocks and cage the beast again
we're talking about a person's mind here
about gene she has to be control control
you have no idea of what she is capable
no professor i had no idea what you were
capable of i had a terrible choice to
make i chose the lesser of two evils
with logan ending up being proven right
as the phoenix's anger at xavier for
caging her would be the catalyst for her
exploding xavier's body and becoming
increasingly unstable which could have
easily spelled the ends of billions of
lives throughout the fox earth and the
fox universe as a whole and with
multiverse madness appearing to have at
least two confirmed nexus beings in it
with this image of two scarlet witch
variants in the trailer it appears that
the relationships and cosmic connections
between powerful nexus beings could very
likely be explored in the film that
follows up the drastic multiversal
repercussions of the runes of cough call
spell because as we learned from doctor
strange in no way home an infinite
number of marvel characters in the
infinite mcu multiverse knew peter
parker was spider-man including infinite
versions of the scarlet witch and jean
grey that knew his identity you know
including the funka jansen and sophie
turner variants of jean grey and since
the ruins of cop call spell has the
potential to reach every human in the
multiverse there is a massive chance of
unintended detrimental effects to the
already fractured and sensitive minds of
cosmically powerful variants like the
scarlet witch and the phoenix force
maybe even cosmically altering their
brain chemistry to the point where
variants of these marvel goddesses can
cause the early terminations of their
home realities which could be why this
version of captain marvel is fighting
this version of scarlet witch in the
trailer in the early termination of
universes is also a huge main struggle
the illuminati have to face in the
comics as they try to stop the
catastrophic crossing over of universes
called the incursions which happen as a
direct result of universes ending before
their time so frankly it would kind of
be irresponsible for professor xavier to
not arrest doctor strange in this
scenario and how freaking dope would it
be to have doctor strange fight two
pissed off versions of jean grey who are
just mad at dr strange for messing with
their minds because they clearly do not
like when professor x does it because
sophie turner was not too jazzed when
her xavier was messing with her memories
in dark phoenix so strange better watch
his ass and then you know probably wash
his ass because if i was strange and i
was fighting two phoenixes i would poop
my pants but those are just the major
cosmic crimes that doctor strange could
have committed that could have caused
the multiverse to just collapse and go
haywire but i don't think that it's
completely fair to put all the blame on
doctor strange so who do you guys think
could actually be to blame for all of
this multiverse madness could have been
the scarlet witch sylvie let us know in
the comment section below because i
would like to sort of dive into this
more in the future and your input could
help us decide who we dive into next so
let's speculate speculation nation
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] but more
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media and if
you do on youtube make sure you hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time you upload a
video and make sure to hit up your
rockstarsmerch.com you get awesome
search like this and all of our
spider-man stuff all of our doctor
strange stuff go check it out i do
rockstarsmerch.com thank you guys so
much for watching this video and
spending time with me love you guys so
much and i'll see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
you